have you seen the story today in the New
York Times evidently the CIA destroyed
tapes of interrogations of al-qaeda
detainees I want to find out what was on
the tapes why they were destroyed no
paper papers were getting people in
trouble met our place at our place
papers how we keep track of laws Adams
so first of all has to say with this
movie it was amazing when I saw it at
Sundance and then when I saw it again
recently so like congratulations and I
really loved it thank you um this one
you're playing a real life character and
I'm just wondering how much time did you
and Dan spend together like getting
ready for this I don't remember how many
months or the timespan was but you
probably meant like a handful of times
and talked about asking questions about
the report that I didn't understand that
was the majority of it me trying to
understand what it was in the script you
know and which parts of the report I
should refer to to make this crit make
more sense and then you kind of like
pick little details about a person you
know I don't have to worry about
physically representing him were
different and Scott wasn't interested in
that so much he was more you know if
there's something about that person that
opens your imagination then then take it
you know I've learned to do that when
you play real people and just disregard
the things that don't align with the
script or don't align with you know your
imagination was pretty good I think I
saw you on like stage together I'm like
I see I could see how like you picked up
on some of his stuff um the other thing
is did he tell you anything that you
found really surprising where you were
like this is incredible it wasn't maybe
in the book or the script you're like
dude I would never say okay I mean
what's in the book is surprising is
surprising enough yeah you know and even
more surprising that people thought it
was like a good idea you know that a lot
of people in key positions of leadership
thought it was a good idea and and given
that we have a lot of documented fact
that it's been a bad idea for so long
that someone would now think that it's a
good idea all of a sudden with is a
shocking watching that part you get the
most frustrated you're like stop just
please stop I will say like I said I was
at Telluride and I watched you get feted
by Martin Scorsese where he went up on
stage and
and you were one of the greatest actors
of your generation so I just want to ask
you how awesome that is cuz I would be
I'd be good I don't do anything else now
after that happened I'm good I don't
want to do anything you know he's he's a
person names of one of my cinematic you
know heroes he's like we have nothing in
common as far as how we were raised
you know or what time we you know but
his movies you know that's a great
Democratic thing about movies is that
they you know they kind of find an
audience and in places that don't have
access to you know meant a lot to me
working with him meant a lot to me and
been a long really boring ways that
moment met you know was you know I'm
inarticulate about it because it because
it's hard to it's hard to describe it it
was very cool a very beautiful moment to
watch and then just kind of wrap it up
you're having a really great 2019 I got
to see you it can with that don't die
which I thought was hilarious
okay and now you're coming with report
after it debuted Sundance oh I'm sorry I
started with the report then dead don't
die pretty soon people are gonna get to
see what I saw in marriage story and
then you just have this little like
indie at the end of the year at Star
Wars the rise the yeah some Jedi think
yeah yeah so talk about your 2018 man
it's too much too much too much of my
face every you know I you know it's not
you make these things I think we shot
marriage story almost two years ago and
I don't know what the timetable but
report less than that that they all
happen to kind of come out at the end of
the year owes coincidental kind of so
it's just it's a lot of talking me
talking badly about the things so it's a
it's all good yeah the United States
does not torture
dan you need to be careful here they
can't destroy the documents and I can go
after the next best thing
yeah first of all guys the first thing I
want to say is is it weird like for you
knowing that you've got the person who's
gonna see you play her like I think that
would make me be kind of paranoid about
it well I definitely took that very
seriously because I wanted to feel I
felt the responsibility to to get that
right and to do enough where one could
accept that that was senator Feinstein
but not too much and i felt the really
the focus needed to be on the story on
the events and the facts and I felt that
the narrative was really strong so I
tried to just adhere to that as much as
I could do you know if she's gotten to
see it are you gonna send are you invite
her to come see I don't know whether
she's seen it or not we we want everyone
to see it because I mean the film is
really about what happened yeah and she
lived it and she was a reluctant
participant this this torture was
exposed the fact that the CIA had this
secret torture program was exposed in
the New York Times so she did her job as
head of the Senate Intelligence
Committee and all of the other committee
members voted that they needed to
investigate what happened from the
beginning 14 to one they voted on the
side of we've got to find out what this
was because this is against the law and
in the end that's what happened in the
end they she was able with Senator
McCain to pass an amendment that
reaffirmed that Americans do not torture
they had we admitted that we did and
then they passed the amendment to just
reaffirm that we are committed to
admitting it when we break the law and
then reaffirming the fact that it's not
going to happen again yeah that's like
the only I guess bright there's a bright
side something that made me okay with
like as you're watching at the end and
you're like okay at least we're gonna
hopefully learn it for the last time
this lesson John I wanna talk about you
because you play more of a composite
character like you're not just one
particular person is that correct no I
played an actual person was Daphne Obama
first administration in the Obama
administration so he's a real dude -
he's out there still he's still talked
in politics probably still on K Street
somewhere I'm not sure what he does now
you gotta talk to him no I didn't get to
meet him but it was there's plenty of
footage of value as the chief of staff
so there was plenty of interviews and
press conferences and whatnot that he
was doing but you know part of the the
tricky part of playing and I think what
the film really does well and what Scott
does so well in the in the script is
explains that this happened under the
Bush administration but was still alive
ish under the Obama administration and
the Obama administration was tasked with
sort of figuring out how to put this
fire out how to how to clean up this
mess mm-hmm and in doing it in a way
that it doesn't look like we're doing it
in a partisan way and saying like we're
blaming all this on you so the fact that
it was secret the fact that it was
deliberately withheld the fact that they
had to come up with this phrase enhanced
interrogation because they didn't want
to call it torture lead you to believe
they knew what they were doing was wrong
so then they had to go out and get
somebody to say well okay well maybe
it's not you know if we can parse the
law in this particular with all this
nonsense so when everybody knew they
were doing something wrong so my
characters job was to say to the head of
this FBI the CIA the Senate get
everybody and go all right we all got to
get on the same page how do we do it and
and that's a that's a tricky role to
play we don't have a lot of natural
negotiators anymore because everyone
staked their claim and there's no one in
the middle yeah no it's right it's
really polarized and hopefully that can
that can remind people that there's room
in the middle last night I found this
he's detaining number 24 I think I know
we watch the video they waterboarded him
183 times everything they got from him
was either a lie or something they
already had if it works why do you need
to do it 183 times maybe one of the
report comes out people will finally see
that gentleman so as I said this was one
of the ones I didn't get it Sundance and
I'm so happy I finally got to see it
recently because it's absolutely amazing
it seems like so many times in the movie
or like I cannot believe they don't
understand this like why don't they just
stop doing this and it's so incredulous
was there any like more crazy things
that like didn't make it into the cut
we're like you're like I can't film this
because no one will believe it I mean I
think there are tons of those moments I
mean if you if you go through the report
itself it's stunning right it means 525
pages were released
there's 2,700 footnotes in that and a
lot of people just read the text and if
that's incredible I can't believe this
happened then you dive into the
footnotes and you find all these other
incredible gems
I think Scott went through the same
process by writing the script right
there's so much you want to include but
only so much time to do it
what is one that we missed like if there
was the bonus features of the report
what is the story that you're like oh my
god we couldn't do this but you know
after the report was after the
techniques were suspended by director
tena the CIA went back to Condoleezza
Rice and immediately wanted the program
reinstated and claimed that there was a
threat against our elections that year
and that they needed the techniques to
use on the specific detainee and the
program was turned back on with the
exception of waterboarding the whole
plot was kind of a fabrication and it
just became too much in the movie in
terms of the frustration and Adam played
those scenes fantastically but it just
it felt like it was one one beat too
many yeah I mean I felt pretty beat down
by it all like through this park so I
can only imagine if you added more
I talked to Adam and he said that Dan
you guys got to have a little bit of
time together like but tell me about
your your intermittent meetings as he
said to like not about everything I mean
well Adams is great right I mean he's so
eloquent about this he was in the
military he knows the military has
always opposed these these techniques
not only because they don't work but it
also puts our troops in danger and and
he also really died into the script and
was the type of person who would call
and ask questions or or reach out and
say I really tell me more about this
piece give me more context even if it
wasn't in the script right understanding
the larger contextual aspects of where
he was and telling the story and it is a
seven-year journey and it is in two
hours and you can kind of see an Adam's
face and eyes time elapsing yeah yeah he
looks pretty beat down by the - like -
are you like oh good they finally got it
together
um spoiler alert sorry also casting him
and Annette and Jon for this film I feel
it's kind of like a dream team so talk
about kind of assembling that group it
was an amazing you know AV Kaufman who
was my casting director in New York read
the script and loved it and said I want
to help and I think one of the
interesting things about the moment that
we're living in is I think a lot of
artists in a lot of different fields are
looking for an opportunity to use their
voice to tell these this kind of story
and the fact that we were shooting in
New York made it easier to get a Tim
Blake Nelson to come out for two days or
Corey Stoll to show up for a day or
Matthew Reese Jenn Morris and maura
Tierney you know Michael C Hall and so
it was incredible to me that we would
ask these people to play relatively
small roles and everyone said yes and
and generally it was because they wanted
to help tell the story which for me as a
director meant a lot but also just as a
fellow filmmaker to know that there are
people who want to do this with their
time
[Applause]
[Music]